[Musik]
schon immer sucht der mensch beziehung
zum göttlichen im eigenen herzen der
natur oder religion
die spirituelle weg sind vielseitig ganz
herzlich willkommen
schön sind sie wieder der viwis eine
spirituelle was wir uns immer unterwegs
im bündnerland und zwar hört im val
lumnezia im look netz doch matthias pubs
und rikki und mutige frauen treffen die
sängerin wo er als leadsänger frau und
jägerin wo mehr ihre kraft dort zeigen
und den alte fast vergessene bruch muss
in dem new kids im tal vor der frau
[Musik]
dafür zählt daher gibt im 14 jahrhundert
frau großenlupnitz mental ihre
starverteidiger grafe aus dem rheintal
und sehr geehrte abhang ganze lawine von
stein und holz aber andere laufen und
hatten so vertrieben
die mutig und tapfere frau aus dem netz
fast täglich bieterschlacht bemerkt habe
darum heißt das alte dorf im da liegen
jetzt auf tour oder barclays auf
romanisch und luk leserinnen sind sieht
er das valle rosas die tapfere das war
netz erstreckt sich forderungen bilanz
bis uwe noch drin
bilanz und zudem kleiner ebene
das sind auch ganz alte werk richtig süd
am anfang von tal liedblatt die stille
im tal viele vom heiligen vinzenz alte
urkunde zeigen dass er dem ort sieht
günther jahrhundert schon immer
gestanden ist
[Musik]
elisa bolliger organisiert führungen zur
kulturgeschichte im liga-betrieb
sportlers mit einem fraunhofer bücher
spielten für alle möglich spezielle
rollläden val lumnezia es hat wird
rüther wunderbar wo natürlich frau also
immer grüßt und für wahr dass mit ihr
braucht es hat frauen heilige ein ganz
alter mit brauer heiligen es gibt prüf
und sagen und mehr so viel von der kraft
und der ideen
text bild wo so schön politik rat ist
werdet ihr fragen zu fachkräften nach
rechts und der verkehrs zur kommunion
als dank normale schon geklärt oder
teure sitzt also traditionell ist das
mehr als alle gern
also es gibt audi ludwig ursprünglichste
hohe vortag nach aus den orient ideale
alter viele zum sonnenaufgang und da
will ich hab mir nicht verkaufen
darum haben wir kick ja sind breit
sicher möglich dass das gesamte platz
die partei hält das linie dafür die
tapfere frau und gerade das riesenbild
vor der schlacht bei lepanto volumen
abbildet sind frauen verschwindet musste
geschichte schrieben geschichte
davon hatten georg entdeckt das sich
aber immer der alte drache umbringt
ja also das ist ja ganz in alter
heiligen austria und drachentöter ist im
zwölften jahrhundert vorher ich das mit
der tracht präsentieren
einfach die er treffen und nach werde
womit ein all dem dunkel fremde
unheimlichen das böse seite bekämpft
tritt müssen mit dem drachen
[Musik]
die hexenverbrennung platz hat sollte
miete vom sie betätigen 100 über 100
jahre lang hexenverbrennung zwölf frauen
und zwei mannes hingebracht worden
aber mir heute frauen ja ich denke idee
eine schwierige titel wo es wirklich
mich sehr dass es in recht weil dort das
tal
seit die linken auf ihrer internet-seite
klare information
das hätte zurück für das man als winter
berücksichtigte aber es sind frauen
wahrscheinlich viel erreicht gehen die
frauen oder niveau hat aber über heute
viel christen tvo eigenständig sie sind
verbrannt worden
[Musik]
elisa bolliger will mehr neu bis
spezielles zeige
im nächsten dorf invasion da geht's
nummer bei 40 der vor zwei kapellen und
empfehle gebührlich und die religiös
werk sind aber eng miteinander verknüpft
im dorf begegneten wieder bekannte
motive sind wie betrag da sind sie als
abwehrzauber oder schutzgeist sony
drache findet man im ganzen tal häufig
vom richtung ferdinand wie oft ein
frauen alte partylocation
[Musik]
das ist jetzt der frauen zwei x 7
heilige frage ganz links ist halt
barbara mit dem kers margareta katharina
katharina hacker ja denn die heilige
ursula die heilig verena und dorothea
mit dem breiten weg und den blumen
machen und die heimische ich dir
maria hat margareta ja für was steht dir
hier hat der drache dazu führt er ist
wahrscheinlich so genau will hat er
kraft und natur was im bild hat die
stadt für fruchtbarkeit firma tour ziehe
ich sicher so eine
madonna auf den mond kam und ist ganz
wichtig für pure und für das wachstum
und blumen und getreide dorothea rieger
ja das wäre für mich katholische
religiöser fertig mit der heilige mann
und frau ist alles geregelt
sie sind standen für qualität wo ganz
wichtig sie ist
[Musik]
ein hofer heilige frage und machen wir
und ein hufe kommt bei einer richtigen
agrarlandschaft probe so darf man die
doppelte geschäft gehört in thal bei
erzählt im mittelalter geboren bartsch
habe sie gedacht viel zu viel fertig
weil auch die heilige herrn örtlichen
eigene vierte kann sich haben wir gar
nicht mehr zum schaufeln
das ist jetzt weniger sie gut sind all
die heilige nehmen so wichtig im leben
der menschen aber hinterhand alte
traditionen unserer user vor der pure
überlebt und es geht frau muss auch von
den alten traditionen inspirieren und
djk stil wohnt pamina caminada sie ist
rüther frau jägerin und die erste wird
hürtherin vom kanton graubünden
im lux kennt sie die heilpflanze er traf
dort und weiß wo man beobachte oberhalb
von dörflicher starten kann ist voller
über zwei meter höhe steigen
seit dem panorama man hier hier hier ist
eigentlich wir steif wurden also das ist
so witzig zu erlaufen
und das sind also die alte steinigen sei
das panorama man hier vorsorge
stilistischer mittel steif um eine
riesen stein kreis vor das selber drogen
panorama man hier und da kann man
verschiedene billiger machen zum
beispiel vom pc regina hin
für lehrer oder andere verbände
wo war kirch die andere linie stehend
oder kraft ortheil kultort und das ist
wirklich dreist die mitte wo vor all den
heiligen katharina oder von der form her
als ob er nie davon aber rama man hier
lügt sagt sehr kritisch das ist eric
schaaf kriegen wir den höchsten ist sich
der broker dorna das sicherheitslevel
aber wenn man alle aktiven verlierer der
depression wirklich von dir da und
besucht und das sind wirklich sehr stark
setzt also die sind nicht so anfällig da
die hemmungslos gerichtet und der die
zünder oder als kalender und zulegt
erhält man hier wirklich bewusst
ausgesetzt weil er absurd und auch bei
aufnahmen mit braucht ist das finden
gut der stadt sagte randolph das oxid
dass man kirchhoff der kraftort gesetzt
hat spaltet er ist sehr schön so die
reihe gen reis bedeutet darüber was die
bedeutet da ist umgebungen das selber
ist getreide selig hat mit dem möglichen
abgangs und einige von denen bei liga
nicht auf 21 2 das sehr wichtiger tag
sie auf den hätten das getreide ausgesät
vorher nicht und dem sonnenaufgang hätte
sind die steine die im schatten geworfen
und wenn das staat vermeinte steigen auf
möglichen streik fallen ist werden dass
alina ag und den helm grüßt jetzt ist
jetzt 23 schweizer gespielt und dann
hätte man das getreide aussehen also
bevor man den kalender card und wie mir
das für treppen steigt
[Musik]
es gibt noch andere rätselhaft ich stets
eine liegt mit dem erwerb und das welt
links soll auf eine sogenannte stört
zone mit strache erstrahle gelegt seit
terminator das stört so stark das war
einfach eine andere energie sucht und
merke zieht aus also ich bin mehrere
zwei es mir ganz fest konzentrieren zum
klar denke also bin ich gespannt
mich selber letzter zeit nötig so das
verwunschene welt lea busch zauberhaft
schön
[Musik]
ja ja ich bin der ort sowie deutlich
rund um das grüne peter disch unter
stress oder liegt über 9 noch immer
stand sie war wie merken sie dass pastor
kraft tisch es ist auf dem herd auf
verhältnis gestört so ne und will man
beim steuer- und tennis ist es ganz
andere schwimmstar also man kann da neu
ordnen handelsproblemen das sorge machen
situation umwandeln und der zelle
ausrichten
das haben wir doch sehr gut mache ok ich
als laie und die sagen welche im labor
ein trick haben ich glaube an den
ortskern mit wohlfühlen und ich ruhig
werde
ja es ist es ist der metrologie treppen
vom thüringer also mit grüner flammer
und roten block und das symbolisiert so
die üblich sind dann auch die möglich
sind
die verwundete heilerin also mit frau
jetzt nur damit sie sich aber auch mit
dem ellbogen problems eine entzündung
der knochen sind ja glauben finden
kultur und ich glaube das wird die
hälfte
nicht sportler
[Musik]
da ich stark sie hat stadt saada mai
kündigt in dem labor des kamins geblickt
[Musik]
ganze vier mal sind das eigene ring
preis krönt aus dem second gar
interessiert zur schulung für das lied
für das margareta liiert aber für die
kulturschätze aus den zahlen nicht viel
verstanden und was gott etabliert es ist
dir sagt die legende von adriana wo sie
personen weniger 15 tag auf der alb
geschafft hat und zwar als mann
verkleidet und rutscht zu fuß auf der
platte und verrichtet bluse und basti
patchen der ritterburg sieht das ist
erfreulich denn sie wenn du mit verrat
ich den krebstod von mir die schönsten
wie wertvoll der sache zum beispiel eher
bluse wo immer wie es wird in die länge
dass du es gleich er seit der kassen
basis für zähler und den steckt sie ihn
letztendlich drei kraft hinter dem
ostalb verlor und seit galt wird von der
bewohner wird für sieger und alle güter
werden immer grüner und so ist es auch
als vermutet also das ist für mich mehr
umbuchbar kite aber sich als liiert
wurde so ein jamaikaner von heiligen
margareta noch versteckt wenn die
heilige margareta ja also in dem lied
kann man sicher ist titel und wo später
angesetzt worden ist christlich und
alles andere ist heidnisch seite aber
eigentlich vorchristliche und rätischen
dahin gut versteckt gc heilige margareta
das ist im erdgeschoss der christen
zieht also quasi ist sie übergestülpt
worden auf die anderen variata und das
ist die christliche fast schon ist sie
wird immer mit dem drachen dargestellt
das heißt sie hat es wilder und
unbändiger cent
georg bringt oder drachen aber sie nicht
hätte ja auch die weibliche energie das
nicht so nötig bis zu töten sondern kann
es vielleicht immer mit anderen
möglichkeiten im romanischen region auch
wenn flüsse über die ufer treten oder
stein schlammlawine also naturgewalten
und der hat der margarete aus antiochia
quasi cent ich habe ganz schöne
darstellung von dani clos obersaxen das
ist mit foto doch als heilige margareta
wurde drachen sogar naturgewalt auf
dauer ja vielleicht ich sie aber auch
wieder eine mischform zwischen
margarethen aus der rhätischen
vorchristlicher zeit wo ja
fruchtbarkeitsgöttin trezia wo man es
vergessen dass
mehr retro mario ermisch sind aus der
römerberg und vertreter dreht jedoch sie
und die hängt die nacktszenen ihren
übernahm wieder das re tischer dass man
mit der natur zimmer ist uniqa sie
deshalb ein katholischer bischof camdal
der cristianos caminada ihn hat das lied
auf fasziniert und dank ihm ist es
überliefert was ist sie vielleicht ist
sie ja ich finde das wunderbar dass er
quasi als als christ und bischof
gewissheit dass in dem tal so viel zügen
sind von der vergangenen zeit fordert
sieht und das hätte ihn nicht in ruhe
glory quiz das ist nicht einfach da
erfand mit jesus sondern das wir
aufbauen andere geschichten dafür ein
anderer geistige haltung in der welt und
das hat er untersucht quasi kretische
brauchtums vorchristlicher
[Musik]
ausgerechnet ein katholischer bischof
der bischof vor hohe cristianos caminada
19 26 gestorben
interessierte für heidnische brauch für
das wort vom rest um dioxin im harz
verdanken unter anderem dass das wird
von der heiligen margareta überhaupt nur
überliefert ist dass man das noch kennt
und als auch interessiert wie denn das
rittertum das heidnische überformt
praxis oder insulin ganz hinten im tal
wirklich der fuchs und hase gute nacht
sagen wird fotos und yamagata hätte
cristianos caminada im luxus zeichnet
der bischof singapur familie
aufgewachsen
die alte brücke und lehrer herr demuth
nach miterlebt rufen erinnerungen
bischof cristianos caminada hat sie
neffe der 87 jährige mina aufbewahrt
denn der alte fotos vom bischof caminada
des konzertes selber schwer
dank das batterien einmal ein bischof
ist derart aber das ist so und so lieber
mensch gewesen und metalle liegt normal
kredite mit wäre viel mehr zeit ohne
bischof nahm sich viel zeit
moment und als dohnányi gerade so
voggenhuber primus
der nev erzählt mir dass der bischof
sich schon früher für alte geschichte
interessiert pure heckenpflege immer
wieder uralte tonscherbe und bronze
reichte kunde und zwar grad neppe turin
auf deinem kleine ab klagt der hügel der
tags zuvor vier musiker bronzezeitliche
mit dem namen christa walter thihatmar
wissenschaftliche ausgabe gemacht und
sehr schöne ton keramik gefunden aber
die krippe ihr sportgerät der 90er jahre
setzt eine große überraschung macht und
hätten vorstand und den hells wir gräber
und der kunde aber nur vor der frauen
[Gelächter]
oder für ein talent vom tal vor der
frage dass wir bestätigen dass man die
theorie schon sehr alt wehrpflicht den
frauen europa mehr als überfällig
[Musik]
das letzte dorf in thal ist frieden am
italienische baustil vor der viele zeigt
sich der fluss am süde fotos rahmen
einer hochebene ist es in laufe früherer
ist dass er wichtige handelsroute sie
blüht und ihre ware bis auf mailand aber
verkauft domina caminada aufgewachsen
dort am natur und umwelt fachfrau immer
wieder heil roter hut vor allem frauen
es ist vor allem das frauen gut also es
ist alles wunderbar schutzgut und
mehreren das so von generation zu
generation heimat dass sie der familie
pflügt und braucht und meine mama und
mein bekannter von mir hält es immer
gesammelt und zimmer mit taubnessel und
aufgabe ein ziemlicher wenn man die
dritte hat den hat man als frau das
leben lang keine schwere kost für sein
team machen es geht also eine das alte
rezept wie überliefert worden ist von
generation zu generation wo es aus 21
brüteten erhöht
[Musik]
malaga bin gespannt ob berliner caminada
als salbe oder social wundermittel hat
viele burgen und ritter
genau
das feuer löschen und der zweck ist
überleben und das ist wie beim kochen
auch dort ihr abitur ihren und mit der
federer kam ist das verfolgerfeld
also sind druck jetzt da die ätherischen
öle wurde jetzt wirken als heilmethode
solches ist in vergessenheit geraten
das braucht der wird also bisher bis
merken 40 minuten ja so paar minuten
[Musik]
jetzt wirkt
die einzige begegnung mit einer frau und
ihrer heil grundstudium müssen eine alte
tradition es sehr beeindruckt es gibt es
richtet
es gibt aber auch andere alte
traditionen und zum teil sind die
mitteln angegangen und auch getrennt die
werke in der nächsten folge ist eine
spirituelle werks immer wieder unterwegs
im bünder land auf eine alte handels und
alte pilgerweg erwähnen zuteil sie im
höchsten wallfahrtsort eurobahn
bis bald
[Musik]